this is tony wilson reading mike
epstein's review of bug snacks
sometimes the name is the game bug
snacks the new game from octodad
developer young horses
is all about catching bugs made of
traditionally appetizing foods like
pizza
strawberries carrots and lollipops which
turn your body parts into food when you
eat them
they're bugs but they're made of snacks
bug
snacks bug snacks it's a wacky conceit
that when paired with the game's cute
and colorful art style puts a smile
on your face and pushes your imagination
to run wild
the surprisingly powerful desire to
discover more about these weird and
wonderful creatures fuels every aspect
of the experience
it's clever if somewhat temperamental
puzzles revolve around catching bug
snacks
the story sends you off to investigate
the mysteries of their home
snacktooth island and its colonists and
though that drive is purely superficial
the game you experience along the way
has a lot of substance
how do i even begin to explain what's
happening in bug snacks
you control an investigative journalist
who's reporting on the expedition of
explorer lizbert megafig to snacktooth
island
where she's discovered evidence of an
ancient civilization
and the delicious mysterious bug snacks
when you arrive
lisboard has gone missing and her colony
snacksberg has disbanded
your goal is to find the colonists
around the island and convince them to
get back together so you can get your
story and find out what happened to the
lost explorer
the world of bug snacks is colorful like
something out of a children's book
all of the humanoid characters are furry
big-eyed muppet-like creatures called
krumpuses
as someone who loves food but hates all
bugs i was delighted to find the bug
snacks all look adorable and charming
the key i think was giving them all arts
and crafts style googly eyes
pulling a page from pokemon each one has
a clever explanatory name
which they say aloud as they crawl
around exploring the various biomes of
snacktooth island
searching out all the inventive little
creatures scanning them to discover
their properties
and observing them in their element is a
pure delight there are 100 bug snacks
some of which are simply palette swap
reskins but finding a new one
is always exciting
to satisfy the former citizens of
snaxburg though you will need to do more
than look
getting your hands on delicious fridays
crapples and rebel peeds requires you to
be clever
catching each type of bug snack requires
a unique puzzle
each one has a different set of
characteristics that dictate how they
react to you
to your tools and to other bug snacks
some will run away when they see you
others will chase some can be caught
using your remote trap
while others will break free and need to
be incapacitated in some way before you
run in and scoop them up with a net
later on some of them are literally on
fire so you need to find a way to cool
them off before making your move
you have a tool kit that gives you a few
options for manipulating the snacks
your slingshot lets you fire different
sauces ketchup
hot sauce ranch chocolate and so on
which can act as bait or repellent
depending on what you're trying to catch
you have a tripwire that can knock over
aggressive creatures and bring down
snacks that are out of reach
more often though you'll need to use
your tools to bring two snacks together
and interact to make them susceptible to
capture
i wouldn't say any of them are tough to
catch but you need to think outside the
box
and that makes you feel clever when a
plan comes together
your interview subjects don't just want
you to catch their bug snacks
they want you to feed the snacks to them
too and when you feed them part of their
body will turn into the food they just
ate
or something related early on you gain
the ability to choose which body part
changes
which turns the bug snacks into cosmetic
items you can continue feeding bug
snacks to any character whenever you
want
giving them a makeover as increasingly
abstract food mutants
as a gameplay mechanic it's a bit
underwhelming in some later
optional missions certain colonists will
ask you to catch snacks with specific
colors or characteristics and apply them
to specific body parts
but that doesn't actually affect how you
catch the bug snacks or the feeding
process
the body changing factors into the story
so it never feels totally superfluous
but the actual mechanic is really just
for fooling around
bug snacks larger story plays out mainly
through the conversations you have with
the colonists once they've returned to
snaksburg
upon their return you get the chance to
interview each one learn more about
their personality and background
and get clues to the larger mysteries of
lizards disappearance and the origin of
the bug snacks
the overarching story is a proverbial
page turner motivating you to keep
moving through it
it's a bit predictable but that didn't
keep me from wanting to see how things
play out
the heart of bug snacks story isn't just
the plot but in its characters
though they look like cartoons colorful
and tropey
residents have real personalities and
personal stories to tell
if you want to hear them after
convincing them to return to town
each character has an optional quest
line in which you help them with their
work and or personal chores
befika the nosy former gossip columnist
asks you to spy on the other colonists
in the middle of the night
trifany the archaeologists wants help
exploring ancient ruins
invariably each character winds up
revealing that they're struggling with
deeper personal problems
difficulty coping with loss or failure
depression anxiety
sometimes you wind up helping them solve
those larger issues
but sometimes you don't even when you
can't though there are touching human
moments when these characters reveal
themselves to you
and shockingly having strawberry horns
or a burrito nose doesn't make them any
less relatable
nice work pal let's go home and we'll
count up the spoils
unsurprisingly bug snacks best qualities
are its cleverness and charm
the surprise and delight you feel when
you see a bug snack wiggling around or
watch someone eat one and change their
arm into food never goes away
that alone would make bug snacks worth
your time but creative puzzles and
thoughtful story give it the body and
depth to make a snack
feel more like a meal
[Music]